KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Hey, Martin.
Have you lost something?
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Katie.
I'm trying to find my wallet.
I forgot to pay
my internet bill,
and I need to find
my credit card.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well, why
not set up automatic payments?
I was just in a meeting
with the team from WebNet,
and we helped them set up
their nightly billing job.
Stay tuned if you
want to find out more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WebNet is a pay-as-you-go
internet provider where you can
set up automatic payments
through their app.
They built a nightly
billing job which
charges the credit
card of any user who
has built up a significant
balance during the day.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Their billing job
runs in Cloud Run,
which is serverless.
This means they don't have
to manage servers or pay
for idle capacity.
Also, it scales up
automatically as load increases.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: They
use Cloud "Shed-juler"
to kick off the
nightly billing job.
MARTIN OMANDER: Don't
you mean Cloud Scheduler?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Nah, I
meant Cloud "Shed-juler."
Cloud Scheduler is
fully managed by Google,
which means that the
team doesn't have
to worry about maintenance.
It just works.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud
Scheduler triggers code
by either making an HTTPS call,
or by publishing a Pub/Sub
message.
The team chooses HTTPS.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: They
configure Cloud Scheduler
to make a POST request
to their billing service
nightly at 1:00 AM GMT.
They also set a JSON
payload that specifies
the minimum balance.
Only customers with a balance
of $5 or more will be billed.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud Run lets
you run code in any programming
language you want, as long
as it's a web service that
can be containerized.
The team has experience
with JavaScript,
so they pick Node.js.
At the top of their code,
they create and initialize
an express app that listens
for incoming HTTP calls.
Note that Cloud Scheduler
uses text/plain content-type,
so they have to tell
bodyParser to parse
more than just the default
application JSON type.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
The post handler
parses the minimum balance
that was sent to it from Cloud
Scheduler, and
then sends that off
to the billing method
later in their code.
MARTIN OMANDER: The billing job
will now be triggered nightly.
But this billing service
is publicly exposed
to the internet, meaning
anyone can trigger it
by posting to the URL.
We need to make
it private so only
Cloud Scheduler can trigger it.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: To do that,
the team edits the Cloud Run
service, removing the allUsers
member from the service, which
makes it private.
MARTIN OMANDER: Next, they
create a new service account
they call Billing Initiator.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: They then
give the new service account
the "Cloud Run Invoker" role.
This means that the
Billing Initiator service
account can trigger Cloud Run
services, but do nothing else.
MARTIN OMANDER: Next,
they copy the email
of the Billing Initiator
service account--
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
And then they open up
the job in Cloud Scheduler and
under the Auth header setting,
select "Add OIDC token."
OIDC, or Open ID Connect, is
a small layer on top of OAuth
that handles identity.
Using OIDC, they can
tell Cloud Scheduler
to use the Billing
Initiator service account
as the identity for the job.
MARTIN OMANDER: Now
the billing service
is closed to the
public, but it can still
be triggered by Cloud Scheduler.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: So the team at
WebNet gave me this US $1 bill.
How much Cloud Scheduler
could they get for that $1?
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, you get
the three Cloud Scheduler jobs
for free.
If they've used those
three jobs already,
they would have to pay $0.10
per month for this job,
regardless of how many times
the job executes in a month.
So that $1 bill would pay for
10 months of Cloud Scheduler.
They would, of course, also have
to pay for Cloud Run, execution
time, and database storage.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
That makes sense.
So what about the--
Martin?
Oh, I guess he didn't
pay his bill in time.
Oops.
[MUSIC PLAYING]